our conversation with the authors of a
best-selling political thriller that's
getting some great great reviews that
would be former secretary of state
hillary clinton and louise penny the
very famous author so their book is
called state of terror it's co-published
by simon schuster which like cbs is a
division of paramount global the women
met through clinton's childhood best
friend her name is betsy eveling
and betsy's no longer with us but she
brought these two together and while
their book is about a secretary of state
named ellen who's got blue eyes who
wears spanx working to stop terrorists
they told us it's also a tribute to
women's friendship including their own
number one this book the whole time i'm
reading it secretary clinton i'm going
did that happen to her who was that in
that meeting
where was she who said what so first
let's get back to where it started well
when i was first approached i did not
think it was a good idea caleb you
didn't no i didn't well number one
because
she is a best-selling author of fiction
i've written non-fiction never written
fiction um
i didn't want to lose your friendship
you know if we were not compatible i was
i was worried i i because i had never
written with someone else i've never
written a political thriller but if
you're going to do it this is the one
you want to do it with and once we
decided okay we're going to stick a toe
in the water
then we got to work on the outline and
what's it going to be about and who are
the characters and what is it that
drives the plot
and that was really one of my favorite
parts of the whole process because we
spent a lot of time facetiming and uh
talking through and then louise asked
the critical question that was a
critical question was finally i asked
hillary what kept you awake when you
were secretary of state what woke you up
at two in the morning okay what were the
nightmares because the book opens
there's terrorist bombing in different
in major cities frankfurt in london in
paris
and i thought that's a good way to start
and then the book is
it's who is responsible for this so it
takes us on a very wild journey but but
i did think though hillary you took us
behind the scenes as to how government
works
you know and i i wondered were you
worried about revealing too much or
worried about how you felt about certain
people because there seemed to be a lot
of were you taking lifting off the
layers and letting us see how it worked
that's really what i wanted yeah i do
okay about that yeah because
um
when you're in these very high stakes uh
situations and where it's so hard to
know
what to do because the facts are
uncertain or even in conflict and the
characters you know they are they hold
these positions but they also bring all
their baggage their personalities their
temperaments their backgrounds and so we
wanted that tension one of the things
that i really appreciate that you
described so brilliantly was the stress
of
having to make life and death decisions
when you don't when you have very little
time and you know you don't have all the
information right there's a love story
in the middle of that too and i'm
curious about who wrote this line
do you know which one i'm going to read
felt his naked white skin as it slid
against her dark moist body
luminous in the afternoon sun she could
feel the weight of him on top of her
lying heavy on her heart was that you
hillary rodham clinton well i
i think it was
a home on a home out of our fertile
imagination that's right for sexting
either
that's as far as we were willing to go
[Laughter]
no but i got such a kick out of it
because i'm thinking
we went oh my god oh my
her character was fun too for me because
she was not a mouse burger but there was
times she accepted stuff and had to suck
it up a little bit yeah this is ellen
the second ellen the secretary of state
that she had to suck it up a little bit
to play her card later yes and i
wondered how many times a if that
happened to you or had that happen oh
yes yes it'd be underestimated and over
delivered but also very firm about what
who she was and what she was going to do
i think it happens to every woman gail i
really do i don't think it's in any way
unique to secretaries of state or women
in government and politics i think it's
where there's the media academia
professions literature whatever it might
be
we're always being underestimated and it
is a very difficult balancing act
sometimes
to
not allow anyone to underestimate you
but to know the timing that is
appropriate for responding so
that was one of the best parts of
writing the book because louise and i
talked a lot about that experience and
what's interesting is that we had the
same experience with the books we were
it was it was underestimated because it
was written by two women of a certain
age
these women of a certain age actually
save the day right and then they and
they don't do it by putting on lycra and
and kicking down doors and picking up
you know little grenade launchers yes
they do it with their brains i mean
there's a certain amount of the other
stuff happening too but they don't need
to resort to that they do it because
they're smart and they're thoughtful
smart and they're thoughtful we like
that state of terror is out in paperback
now wherever you like to buy their books
you can clearly tell they have a great
rapport they had met even before they
met this wrote this book in 2016 louise
lost her husband and hillary clinton who
didn't even know her wrote her a note of
condolence about her husband yeah and
louise was very touched by that and she
said they were both mourning hillary's
mourning the loss of the election right
she was mourning the loss of her husband
and their best friend her best friend
brought them together now those two are
very tight and you can see they have a
lot of fun together yeah she was tickled
when you started talking about the
steamy parts of this book that's for
sure
they still didn't tell me who wrote that
line right right